Harrison ford has played some of the most iconic male heroes ever to appear on
film.
The cultural impact with his filmography is so massive that it's hard to
overstate an entire generation of young boys learn to idealize his cinematic
performance of masculinity.
These films provided an education of sorts into what it meant to be a man.
I'm Solo Indiana Jones and Rick Deckerd have a lot in common.
They're lovable.
Rogue is who chart their own path and take what they want.
They may be assertive or cocky,
but in the end they're always frame
as good guy.
Growing up,
I watched Harrison Ford's movies dozens of times,
but going back and watching the scan as an adult and he's struck by something
else they have in common,
something dark,
correct
thing I hadn't noticed as a kid,
or at least didn't really have the language to articulate.
I don't know.
I have a bad feeling about this.
Yeah.
If you look beyond their charisma,
Deckerd Han and Dr. Jones all treat women badly.
So in this video,
we're gonna take a closer look at four iconic scenes from Harrison Ford's Korea,
all of which illustrate and unsettling pattern you choose,
essentially framed as as deductions and plays out a similar dynamic,
the dynamic of Predator and prey.
Most critics agree the empire strikes back is the best of the original star wars
trilogy.
The film takes a darker tone and focuses more on its character development,
flushing out the relationship between Han Solo and Princess Leia.
Yeah.
Now keep in mind that haunted lay,
I haven't had no romantic relationship up until this point.
In fact,
their interactions have been tense to say to them
least.
Oh,
please.
Oh good.
Excited being held by you isn't quite enough to get me excited.
Sorry sweetheart.
Time for anything else.
I'd like to focus on one scene in particular,
a scene that's often cited as one of the most romantic in cinematic history.
Let's count the number of times that Princess Leia directly or indirectly
indicates that she's not interested in Hahn's advances.
Hey,
your worship.
I'm only trying to help you.
Please stop calling me that.
Sure.
We make it so difficult.
Sometimes I do.
I really do.
You can be a little nicer though.
Come on.
Admit it.
Sometimes I think I'm all right.
Occasionally,
maybe when you are an acting like a scoundrel,
Scoundrel town.
I like the sound of that.
Stop that.
Stop.
Boy.
Stop that.
My hands are dirty.
Dirty too.
What do you find out?
Frey?
You're trembling.
I haven't like Nice,
nice man.
I isolated the reverse power flux coupling
in addition to its function in advancing the plot.
This scene is sending us a whole bunch of messages about masculinity,
about men,
and about romance with women.
The scene only lasts about a minute and a half during which time she rebuffed
his advances eight different times with both verbal and nonverbal communication
and he ignores and disregards her each time.
Some will of course,
object to this reading of the seat.
They'll point out that as viewers were supposed to infer that layer despite her
repeated objections secretly really wants it and that therefore it's okay for
Hong to disregard for work.
I have no doubt that that is how the scene is meant to be understood and therein
lies the problem.
The troubling implication here is that when women say no,
they don't really mean it,
that when women say no,
it's just part of some courtship game were good girls play hard to get and that
men are therefore justified in continuing to pressure them until they finally
gave in
in perhaps his second most famous movie role.
Harrison Ford's character continues the same predatory behavior.
Indiana Jones not only refuses to listen to women when they say no,
he also uses course to get what he wants.
I'm allowing you to tag along.
So one or two the rest.
Okay,
dawn,
what do you mean
tag along?
Ever since you got into my club,
haven't been able to take your eyes off.
Oh yeah.
At the end of Indiana Jones and the temple of doom leading lady.
Really?
Scott has clearly had no,
I mean these antiques,
which of her life in danger at least a dozen times over the course of the film.
So when he suggests she accompany him on another adventure,
Willie rebuffed him and no one's hurt.
It's a long way to Delhi.
No thanks.
No more adventurous with U.
Dot.
S
wait heart after all the fun we've had together.
Do you think I'm going to Delhi with you or any else after all the trouble
you've gotten me into thinking again,
buster,
I'm going on in Missouri where they never feed you snakes before,
rubbing your heart out lower,
even the hot.
This is not my idea of a swell time.
She makes it clear that she's not interested and she walks away.
Indeed doesn't listen.
Excuse me sir.
I need a guide to Delhi.
He forcibly prevents her from leaving,
pulls her back to him and kisses him.
It's important to note here that willy is written to have a positive response to
indie's aggressive behavior.
Her Reaction Reinforces the myth that women secretly want it even and especially
when they explicitly say no.
The scene also contains another regressive message,
one about women's anger,
but we'll get back to that in a moment.
Let's skip ahead to a scene in Indiana Jones and the last person just like in
Temple of doom.
Indie and Elsa have not had a romantic relationship up until this point.
Knock it off.
You're like,
no,
I don't do things the same way.
You'd still be standing at the Venice.
What do you think is going on here?
Since I've met you,
I've nearly been incinerated drowns,
shot at and chopped into fish page.
We're caught in the middle of something sinister here.
My guest,
his dad found out more than he was looking for and until I'm sure I'm going to
continue to do things the way I think they should be done.
How you kiss me
and here's where the narrative begins to reinforce more of those dangerous ideas
about courtship.
If that had been the end of it,
it could have served as a lesson and what men should not do.
Alas,
Elsa is written to reaffirm the same dangerous myths that we've been talking
about in all the scenes so far.
I don't like fast women and I hate arrogant.
The idea that women secretly want men to force themselves on it.
These two scenes are played as humorous,
but both still reinforce another pernicious idea.
The idea that women's anger isn't real,
that women's anger is instead an invitation to men to continue their advances.
For most of my life.
I said that blade runner was my favorite film of all time.
I don't say that anymore.
Ridley Scott's in 1982 masterpiece includes perhaps the most disturbing Harrison
board,
so cold Romeo scenes,
the film frames of violence,
sexual assault,
committed by its protagonist as a of seduction.
First,
a little context.
Rick Deckerd has just informed Rachel that our memories are fake and that she's
not a human being as she previously believed,
but a machine keep in mind that it's deckards job to kill androids.
Androids like Rachel Deckerd is drunk and Rachel is distraught
and he takes advantage of this vulnerable moment to kiss her.
When she doesn't respond to his advances,
he moves in again,
she backs away,
gets up,
grabs her coat and quickly heads for the door,
but like all the scenes we've looked at so far,
our hero refuses to take no for an answer.
Here's where it crosses the line into sexual assault.
Deckerd responds to rejection by getting angry and turn violent.
He punches the door closed,
grabs her,
shoved her against the window,
pins her there and then forces a kiss on her,
has tender music,
starts playing to indicate to the audience that we are now supposed to find all
of this seductive,
the implicit threat of violence ways on everything in the scene.
The scene includes many of the same dangerous messages we saw in previous
examples.
Again,
we see the myth that women secretly want it
and again,
the myth that women will respond positively to male aggression gets all here,
but there's something else going on as well.
We see decorative employing the tactics of a serial abuser to understand what I
mean.
Let's rewind and watch part of that scene again.
Well,
pinning Rachel against the window.
Deckerd orders her to kiss.
Yeah.
When she tries to protest,
he doesn't listen
and commands her to ask for it.
Just so we're all clear on what's happening here.
Deckerd is forcing Rachel to give him consent under the threat of violence after
physically attacking her and trapping her and his apartment
with decker is doing is shifting the blame and the culpability for this assault
away from himself and onto Rachel.
He's forcing her to make the assault her fault.
He's forcing her can literally ask for it.
This is a particularly insidious form of emotional manipulation that's commonly
used by men who commit domestic violence.
Lead runner is about a man in crisis,
a man uncertain about his job,
his place in the world,
and his own humanity,
but instead of facing that internal struggle,
Deckerd reasserts his own power by exerting power over women,
especially Rachel
in many ways.
Harrison Ford and represents the paragon of all American Hollywood man who route
the eighties and nineties he was an almost unparalleled cinematic role model.
His movies offered us lessons in how to be a man,
had to be a good guy,
had to be,
yeah,
but they also taught us that aggressive sexual behavior is something that women
admire and that young men and boys should emulate.
The tactics of invading a woman's personal space,
aggressively propositioning her multiple times and putting her in a very
uncomfortable position of having to reject you.
These are strategies that are right out of a pickup artist playbook.
It's the predatory worldview that's at the heart of what's often referred to as
rape culture.
Films that confuse coercion or abuse forced seduction are of course not limited
to just Harrison Ford's nomography.
The conventions of predatory manhood are part of a long running Hollywood
tradition in popular movies,
television shows,
and music.
In the three decades since the release of blade runner,
very little has changed in terms of many of manhood.
Take this scene from specter,
their most recent James Bond film,
which was released in 2015
it killed him
to my husband.
He was an assassin.
Trust me,
he won't take it personally.
You're signing my death warrant.
The movement and blocking in this scene tells the whole story and it's a
familiar one.
Notice that bond is always advancing on her and she is always backing your way.
Well,
I can tell you the deck on the trust you then you have impeccable packable
stinks.
James Bond is in the role of the Predator that slowly stocking and then trapping
his prey I can think of was the implicit threat of bonds.
Violence permeates everything in this interaction as it does with decker in
blade runner
James Bond.
Again,
we see the aggressive nature of this scene framed by the film as a form of
seduction.
The film is telling us that men don't need to listen to women,
that they should take what they want aggressively,
if necessary.
That once backed into a corner once coerced,
women will finally admit that they secretly wanted it all along,
even if they said no.
As the movies we just looked at illustrate,
men in our culture are socialized to believe that it's acceptable to pressure or
coerce women.
When women say,
no,
Han Solo,
Indiana Jones and Rick Deckerd don't hear that.
They like too many men in our culture instead here not yet.
Or keep trying.
Despite the lessons of Hollywood style masculinity,
when women indicate that they're not interested in something,
that is never an indication to keep trying the absence of a heart,
no.
Or even a very reluctant yes is not enough.
Because if that's all that's required,
it opens up the door for forms of coercion and manipulation and it should go
without saying that coercion and manipulation have absolutely no place in
romantic or sexual relationships.
What we should be looking for instead is an enthusiastic yes.
Okay,
here we are.
The affirmative or enthusiastic model of consent encourages open,
proactive communication,
mutual excitement and respect.
Do you like it?
Like it?
I love it.
I could kiss you.
I could.
I mean,
I'd like to,
I may.
I we me,
I mean,
maybe we wait,
what
if you'd like to see more videos related to media and manhood,
you can help fund the pop culture detective agency over on our patriot.